joining me now live from kiev is
president zielenski's
press secretary sergey nikiferov thank
you very much for being with us i don't
know whether you managed to hear
what i was talking to mr peskov about
but uh what did you make of it if you
did
good evening mark thanks for having me i
heard parts of it yes
just before the break
so i mean basically it was a flat denial
of war crimes he said in essence that it
had been
all the incidents had been staged for
the benefit of the western media
um
you know um
let's um
look russian officials were telling that
um ukrainians uh had shut down mh17
it appeared
they didn't russian officials had said
that
they didn't poison navalny it appeared
they did russian officials
had said that they didn't poison uh
there was no salisbury poison in skripal
family poisoning it appears it was
uh worse mentioning also it it's a very
long it's a very old story but worth
mentioning here the twin ankle story
right both committed on on
uk soil
just before the war russian officials
were telling that uh they are not going
to attack ukraine
they were going to attack ukraine so
um
all these lies repeatedly said by
russians appeared to be false you know
so is there any reason to believe mr
pisco now i i highly doubt
that
tell me about what's happening in
butcher and in the other places north of
um
of kiev that have the the russians have
moved away from uh what what is going on
and what are you finding there
yes russians actually they didn't move
away they were forced to uh
withdraw from there because they had no
military success during you know during
weeks and weeks so they were forced to
retreat to concentrate their efforts on
the eastern part of ukraine because they
failed
to do at least anything just uh
next to kiev they they failed to even
approach kiev they were stopped uh
again as you said in bush enterprise it
was almost those uh small towns to the
uh
northwest of kiev so
they left them
and as uh ukrainian forces were
uh taking over those small towns they
discovered these horrible horrible
things like civilian muskrains mass
graves filled with uh corpses of
civilians many people
were
shot in the in the back of their heads
so clearly executed
many of them had their hands and the
legs tied
the majority of killed now is more than
400 corpses uh our
civilians are civilians
right and you pass the evidence we
sorry to interrupt you you'll pass the
evidence on to the
international
criminal court with you because
will you because
one of the things he was pointing out
was that russia is now claiming that
ukrainians are committing war crimes
uh
will those be investigated as well
uh what do you mean so so i spoke to the
i that he was claiming that uh the
ukrainians are also committing war
crimes i mean clear
you know there is no equivalence in
terms of scale or anything but
will they be in will they be
investigated as well i spoke to your
chief prosecutor and she suggested they
would be
yes all
all the
presumed war crimes committed on
ukrainian soil will be investigated
both presumably committed by ukrainians
or russians and uh to be honest ukraine
has a
successful very successful experience of
actually investigating
uh war crimes
of
some of the ukrainian troops after the
initial stage of the war in 2014 2015.
they were those
crimes were investigated those people
were brought to court and they were
sentenced so ukraine has a successful
story of persuading war criminals
uh can russia does russia have the same
story of persecuting its own war
criminals i know nothing about that
just finally
you must
fear what
is eventually going to be found in
mariupol
uh
let alone mariupol we still have to
investigate everything that happened in
kievoblis because after it being and
after bucha we have barayanga where the
situation is according to some our
officials is twice as
as as hard as grape as in uh
in bush so we have to
reach all the smallest cities in kiev
hobless and of course uh
seeing we where
we have very limited access to
to pictures and from into videos from
mariupol but even seeing that
uh it's really it's terrifying
to
to expect to imagine
what could have happened there because i
mean the scale of the city because
mariupol is a half a half a million has
had unfortunately had half a million of
inhabitants
so um yeah you're right uh you're right
we uh we tend to to believe that those
uh
um the behavior
of russian troops the the feeling of
impunity
has the you know systematic character so
the bharatyanka and the european and
bush
unfortunately
um
i mean very hard to say but
unfortunately we believe that those are
not the exceptions that the general rule
is
manner of behavior of russian troops
and
the feeling of impunity that allows them
to
commit such an atrocities towards
civilians okay mr keefer of appreciate
your time as well thank you very much
indeed thank you very much